Huff Mikey Mike when are we bringing
back audience selected music
unfortunately not today because
Professor Jacob picked this song I
actually I legitimately have to have a
Content warning here this is apparently
rather disturbing not only like sexually
but spiritually so it's got 11 million
views in 10 days and it's number two on
YouTube trending music so we should
probably talk about it I'm not afraid to
know demons I don't seek him out I don't
like him you know but God is much more
powerful than demons and it's good to
see the culture straight on so anyway Ms
cat take it away
yeah
hey
how my demons
[Music]
what's up
I am on the bigger things
bought a limousine
like me in your dreams
[Music]
all right let's put a pause here I just
want to pause so it stops
notice what she says she because usually
when these Libs put out some song with
overtly satanic or
um demonic imagery they'll at least
pretend that it's some sort of metaphor
you know no I don't really worship Satan
this is even what the Temple of Satan
says they say well no we don't really
worship Satan we're just doing it
ironically you know it's just a metaphor
you think well man if you ironically
worship the devil for your whole life
you're doing it earnestly actually
you're not fooling anybody's sweetheart
when you
are worshiping an evil metaphysical
entity obviously that is going to have
some metaphorical aspect to it but it's
still it's real man you know
metaphysical things are real there is
Spirit In addition to matter and so
you're actually worshiping the devil and
what she's saying though is the metaphor
here is how do my demons look now that
my pockets are full yeah now that you
b-i-t-c-h-e-s's are shook how do my
demons look so it would seem that the
people she's calling her demons are her
critics he says yeah my pockets are full
though I've got a lot of money so how do
my demons look now it's so on the nose
that it's hard for me to believe she's
not aware of this but sin does blind
people the answer to how do your demons
look when your pockets are full is more
ready to pounce than ever this is what
our Lord means when he says it's it's
harder for a rich man to enter the
Kingdom of Heaven than for a camel to
pass through the eye of a needle
yeah material material wealth is not a
bad thing in itself but it can increase
the temptation to focus on worldly
things rather than Heavenly things and
it can it can ensnare you and entrap you
which is why our Lord also asks what
does it profit a man to gain the whole
world but to lose his soul and she's
saying no now that I'm rich though my
demons meaning my human enemies but
those aren't your demons your human
opponents your your human enemies for
that matter they're not the people that
you need to fear because ultimately you
should fear God and you should fear not
only the punishments of God but
disappointing God you should fear
betraying God because God is infinitely
good and deserving of all your love okay
keep going
[Music]
Queen
queen I am expeditiously
[Music]
I would never let you in my VIP we are
enemies we are foes who are you
what are those
you are gross
[Music]
so she's performing as the demon in
addition to the character as herself
right the demons are are voicing some of
the words which is
telling more than perhaps she knows
because the answer is how do my demons
look now that my pockets are full they
look like me
no it's just not how you how you want
them to look keep going
[Music]
the class out I take the trash out put a
pause there she's even describing the
rise to fame and power she says look I'm
a puppet I'm a sheep I'm a cash cow
I'm a cow
[Music]
Randall there is a cow outside there's a
cow Farm you're gonna plant house
outside yes I'm she's bragging about
this she's saying I'm so big I'm so
famous I've got so much money but then
she's admitting yeah I'm just a puppet
though I'm a puppet for the record
companies I'm a puppet for Hollywood I'm
a puppet for the entertainment industry
in a higher sense though who are you a
puppet for you're a puppet for those
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places that govern
this world but she says I'm the fastest
growing b i t c h on all your apps now
and all these people that want what I've
got their hopes and dreams are dashed
and I love that oh yeah I'm full of Envy
somehow even now that I'm more
successful somehow I'm even more envious
somehow I'm I'm just I'm not even happy
I'm just vengeful I'm more vengeful than
ever even though I've got everything
that I pretended that I wanted
and then what she said she goes after
the I done took the spotlight and made
them black out I made my enemies
blackout it's not even I want what I've
got I just don't I want my enemies to
not have what they want she then goes I
done took the whole um
wait for it
but I don't get it male organ oh God
that is disgusting I mean I'm not going
to repeat the rest of the line but she's
describing how a lot of people gain fame
and fortune in Hollywood which is they
sell their bodies for sex which is what
she is doing I mean even if she didn't
literally do what she's saying she did
here her schtick is she just kind of
dances provocatively not wearing a lot
of clothing in this case she's doing it
in a costume that is demonic but sexual
immorality always has a connection to
the Demonic so she's bragging she's
saying hey I sold my body for sex and
I'm a puppet and I'm a sheep and I'm
nothing but a cash cow but look I got my
pockets and what do my demons look like
now they look like me I have become a
demon okay keep going
[Music]
foreign
get me out of here the normal ladies
just saying get me out of here and she's
right I liked that video more than I
expected I think it's also a pretty good
portrayal of demons they're tempting
towards sexual immorality
disproportionately but that they also
attempt all the other Envy avarice all
these sorts of things and they look like
shadowy figures they're in Black when
people have described having demonic
Visions where you see just traditional
depictions of demons throughout history
they're often they're you know kind of
shadowy and they'll and they're crawling
around like bugs I think I often think
of demons as sort of like bugs you can't
actually sell your soul to the devil the
devil that's just another trick of the
devil because you your soul doesn't
belong to you God owns your soul and um
you owe it to God she certainly thinks
she sold her soul to the devil and she's
certainly making a choice to worship
demons and I'm sure it's making her a
lot of money and what does it profit a
man to have the biggest music video on
YouTube and your pockets full of money
but to lose your soul
a Michael and all this is the Michael
Knowles show see you tomorrow
foreign